I'm home! Good morning, John, it's January
5th and I'm sitting in my basement back home,
surrounded by all the things I love.
I love orange juice. I love Mental Floss magazine
and Benjamin Franklin. Everything is reversed
when I look at it on the computer. I thought
he was over here. I love these old collages
that were on my wall in college that I still
have taped together because I think maybe
someday I'm gonna put 'em back up on a wall
someday. I love that, right there. You see
it? There. That's a map of the realm of Narnia.
Yeah, it's a map of the realm of Narnia. Hold
on, I have to go upstairs and get something.
Movie magic! Lies of omission. What did I
get? We don't actually have Strawberry Hill
here. I didn't know that. I never looked for
it. Until today. Alas, Sutter Home White Zinfandel
will have to do.
It's gonna be kind of embarrassing if I have
any of this left in the fridge when friends
come over, but it's your challenge and you
did stick several pieces of toilet paper in
your mouth and discussed the political situation
in Nepal. I'm glad that I wasn't stuck with
a political situation in Nepal challenge because
I don't actually know anything about Nepal.
Except maybe that there's rocks, and that's
only really because there are rocks everywhere.
A commenter suggested that I drink a glass
of Strawberry Hill wine and then say "Eat
five sheets of toilet paper while discussing
the political situation in Nepal" really fast
without vomiting. I'm going to do that.
Now there's only one way I'm going to be able
to do that. And that's by eating corn dogs.
Eating corn dogs is the only way I can chug
an alcoholic beverage without puking. I don't
know why. I think maybe my stomach's just
like, "Oh that corn dog is so good, I can't
let go of it! I have to hold on to the corn
dog. I don't care how much alcohol you pour
in me, just don't let go of the corn dog!"
I really like corn dogs.
It's not Strawberry Hill, but it only cost
$3.65. Ugh! Bugligigligah. To brotherhood.
Eat five sheets of toilet paper while discussing
the political situation in Nepal! HOOAH! That
really wasn't all that hard. What was all
the fuss about?
(singing) Eat five sheets of toilet paper
while discussing the political situation in
Nepal.